[Music]
what up everybody my name is ross
panetta
chef and owner of via kitchen and today
we're going to be testing out five
celebrity burger recipes to see which
one is the best and today's lineup we
have
alvin kailan kylie jenner nick offerman
jason derulo and a very very interesting
recipe from dean martin i measured out
all the ingredients
exactly as the recipe stated and i
brought three of my friends here to
figure out which one of the burger
recipes is their favorite so which one
of these celebrities has the best burger
recipe
let's get it cracking so up first we got
alvin khan land he's gonna start out
with some ground beef
we're gonna cut up some onions into nice
little rings
keep them real thin he seasons both
sides of the patty heavily with salt and
pepper for maximum flavor
you're gonna stuff with american cheese
for a nice little surprise in the middle
we're gonna form some paddy balls to
resemble a baseball and he's gonna
thread it on the outside with some
onions
he cuts up some martin's potato rolls
and sticks some american cheese in the
middle to make a grilled cheese for the
top and the bottom of the bun
after this we're gonna go ahead and sear
our patties we're going to add some
butter for
basting so the reason why alvin adds
butter while basting is to cook it
evenly and add flavor
and we're going to throw in some
american cheese on top for assembly he
puts a thousand island dressing on the
top on the bottom
and some onions and there you have it
alvin kailan's baseball burger
this one is huge it doesn't look like a
regular burger
and i don't know how i'm going to fit it
into my mouth it has a lot of cheese
it looks like it has two layers of mini
buns of cheese
this one's really good this burger is
pretty meaty the sauce on it kind of
tastes like the
like the shake sack sauce this is like
ordering a burger extra cheese extra
cheese extra cheese
i have the sweet kind of taste this is a
burger that i would order this one
tastes really good definitely something
cool
i wouldn't per say say if i want to have
like a whole burger of it maybe just
a small amount just because there's so
much cheese it's decent
up next we got kylie jenner so in her
ground beef she adds garlic
salt pepper larry seasoning salt and
surprisingly some teriyaki sauce for
some extra flavor
we're going to form patties syrup in a
cast-iron skillet don't add me i know
it's not burnt it's just caramelized
from that teriyaki sauce so we're going
to add some white cheddar
steam it to get the cheese extra melty
for assembly she got some nice toasted
buns bacon
ketchup pickles and there you have it
kylie jenner's burger
so this one looks like a regular burger
something that you make like when you
have like a quick barbecue at home
i'm gonna try it even though i don't
like pickles
this one's different there's something
in it i definitely taste the teriyaki in
the burger
pretty decent something i would not
order i like it
i wouldn't compare to anything i had
before but maybe if
there was a japanese american restaurant
mixed together
that's what i kind of grabbed from this
burger it's good would i buy it no
but it's good up next we got dean martin
aka my man young dino surprisingly his
burger recipe is very simple we got some
nice ground beef forming into a patty
salt the cast iron skillet because
that's what it says in the instructions
we're gonna sear it
to a nice medium rare
and to finish off his burger dean martin
likes to wash it off with two ounces of
nice bourbon
i don't know what this is i think you
might have to call the cops
because a criminal probably cooked this
there is no bun there is no
condiments there it's just the burger
try it
no flavor no salt kind of like something
you get like a baseball stadium or
something
i feel like i'm eating a dry meatloaf
come to the side of bourbon
so i'm going to take a little sip oh
that's strong foods
yeah i like it good if i was on a diet
and i was trying to
just enjoy a burger i would eat this but
i am not on a diet
so i will not eat this so next up we got
jason derulo's burger recipe we had to
scale it down because there was really
no recipe on tik tok but what we have so
far
is salt pepper larry seasoning salt
garlic powder and paprika
we're gonna form it into some patties so
jason uses warm donuts as his bun so
we're gonna throw that in the oven and
toast it
while we make our burgers so these
burgers are pretty hefty so
we're gonna sear them on each side for
about four to a half to five minutes
for assembly he tops his burger with
some american cheese some bacon
some onions and a randomized piece of
lettuce because i mean i guess we gotta
keep it somewhat healthy right
this one looks fun i see that it has
donuts as
buns let's check this one out
the flavors kind of explode in your
mouth which is pretty good it has a
balance of
sweet and savory it doesn't really taste
like a donut kind of tastes more like a
sweet bun like a like a hawaiian roll or
something like that really good
i feel like you would find this at a
food truck where they're trying new
things
i would definitely go and buy this and
last but not least we got nick
offerman's manly ass burger
he starts off with cutting a wild amount
of onions up and sauteing it in a pan
with some oil
and garlic what you want to do is saute
it until you get a little bit of color
he's going to add that to the beef he
makes some sort of like a meatloaf style
recipe he's going to add some parmesan
cheese and egg
to bind it all together it'll form some
patties and sear it off nicely
you want to achieve a nice medium rare
he's going to top it off with some
cheddar cheese
and we're going to steam it so it can
get all nice and melted
for assembly we got some nice white
toasted american buns crispy fried bacon
and a nicely fried egg
the last burger looks pretty good has
like a nice amount of cheese
a nice fried egg on top let's try it out
this one's kind of just regular it
tastes really good i do like a fried egg
on my burger
i feel like this will be a good
breakfast burger if you have leftover
meat patties and the next morning when i
add a fried egg on top
this burger kind of seems like a burger
from a diner it's a good average burger
that's high nothing crazy so now that
we've cooked
and tried all the burger recipes which
one is the best one
here we go at least five celebrity
burgers my favorite one was definitely
number four the donut bun it tasted kind
of like a
wine roll it was really sweet it went
really well with the meat who made it
jason oh that's my guy
out of these five celebrity burgers i
think i would have to go
with the last one it's very straight to
the point very simple
the egg the cheese the buns
okay i heard of him it's good if i had
to choose between
all of these i would choose number four
the
donut and the burger went so well
together and especially having the bacon
it had sweet and
kind of like a salty taste to it
oh really it's like a tick tock food god
and there you have it guys jason derulo
takes today's
favorite celebrity burger recipe cheers
jason darullo
picked up so which celebrity recipe
should we try next
leave a comment below
[Music]
you